hello there reject nation today is what
you call a
self-indulgent day and also you know
where the birthday party they're having
on outside
the pandemic's over but we're we're all
free now
we're all vexed and we can do it so a
couple days
ago uh we did a reaction to gom films
video
uh of captain america reacting to john
walker kills
and then gom films george he actually
saw our video he loved it and he sent us
an email saying these incredibly nice
things uh not only about our reaction
but especially what we said during the
commentary side of our reaction
and during the commentary we made a
little joke of like he should dub us
and apparently he went ahead and just
did that he took our advice and dubbed
us
like sorry to ruin the traction on the
channel you were
man that was ain't getting to get the
views that most you've been getting late
this is gonna get you trending oh my god
like first his words were much needed
that day
it was like a few paragraphs of an email
we were so touched to receive that email
and then to know that you actually went
ahead and did this sincerely very much
honored and i i can't wait to watch it
because your content is sincerely
hilarious
it's so funny and there's a lot of work
that does go into it so i know this took
some time
i haven't even seen a second of this so
i'm excited to see what it is
oh so sweet
so sweet and at this point it's all
getting
pretty official thank you
not one but two villains one of which is
of a plot leak from somebody who has
proved accurate in his league
[Music]
[Music]
mustache
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice
that when i'm so when a pig isn't a pig
it's specifically your fault kid i'm
doing this
is
this could be
[Music]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
and leave a comment below
and check out the real questions
check us out all right yeah all right
all right yeah take care
bye that's not a bad impression man
my my throat hurts so much right now oh
that was so
funny i'm so honored this is so surreal
to me i know
i never thought in a million years this
would happen we are doing it
uh yeah what's funny is i'm like you
know you catch john and i on a
particular day
this could just be a conversation we're
happy with each other
i like kanye west oh
that's a great boy i got a purple heart
a lot of times we do behave like
frankenstein's monster meets the big
lebowski you know
we're one yeah yeah or the dude or the
dude
the franken dude he really captured the
laid-back
stoner-esque personality that we possess
and just the sort of i don't know i feel
like you could super cut
us just making i i make a lot of just
arbitrary noises during things and so i
feel like you especially honed in
on those because between the two of us i
feel like we have a good uh vocalization
range
how do you how did you do that where you
isolated the cosmic wonders
did you have to get cosmic wonders video
probably and then have to sync
that up too and then do the voice for me
then the voice for him
have to make all that he probably did
this probably was probably took a long
no they they all are harder than they
look yeah yeah yeah because
he's also doing the thing that like bad
lip reading will do where you try to
have a little bit of a
fl of a like conversational flow to it
it's not like a
you know a dramatic scene or something
but you know like the kanye west bit
there's something yeah there are
recurring bits uh motifs they're
recurring motifs
well it's funny because the kanye west
thing yeah i do like kanye west i find
to be a very fascinating individual
well dude and you could easily be the
next kanye like
yeah that's true and for the record you
know i know the difference between
sam wilson and kanye west so haku three
edits in the video and the comments said
this is literally the best birthday
present today
joshua and kale the cosmic one are
getting some love yeah
i thought i was really watching real
rejects reacting to geo m
films you can be you can be dude i'm
so honored i love when i mean yeah like
this doesn't happen very often and it's
always
this has never happened john what do you
mean this doesn't happen very often
we've never been dubbed
yeah so what do you say this doesn't
happen very often well you know like we
have a friend named
jean who like you know made like a try
not to laugh out of us and that was
very mean like tribute videos yeah for
us yeah like a video
oh yeah i make those for us all the time
oh
you do that i make many videos and
that's why i mainly highlight me in
there
and not that makes sense i was wondering
why every real rejects tribute i come
across
is just you and there is an expose video
i'm working on
for you specifically oh good that i
think you're
really good well you won't like it but
it'll get views but we'll get that
hashtag going again again in the live
streams we'll get that cancelled john
going again
party bringing on aaron from invincible
so that way when invincible's done
bam i released my expose video boom
you're out aaron and this channel's more
woke
dude yeah it's probably for the best
though you know
i've had a good run being a white guy on
this channel
we can we can move on to something more
progressive right
guys right see what i mean
now we should do a dub of you but would
m does we talked extensively about it in
the captain america one i'm
so curious to know what the process
would be like are you watching this
in silence like the whole first time
knowing what moments to isolate because
that video that we did that he's pulling
from
is like a 15 to 20 minute video i forget
how long it is but it's it's lengthy and
this video itself is only four minutes
so he has to edit
all this together and write up what the
dialogue will be and try to match all
this it's it's
a lot of hard work i'm very so like to
know that you went out of your way to do
this
i very much appreciate that and and also
i mean geo went through hell to get this
thing like the computer
died part way through making this video
and he had to go and get it fixed so
like out there there's probably an even
longer cut of it oh my god
release the geodesic the johnx mosaic
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here g.o.m
i love this thank you for making it i
love you for for what you're doing and
you'll be at a million subscribers
before you know it absolutely you're
growing so much already
i know he did say i haven't replied to
this yet in this moment and he said
i hope you guys get a laugh out of my
dub i did of you guys
i'm not too familiar with you guys what
i like about the video i saw of you guys
he says you guys reacted to my video was
that you're clean
no swearing and dirty stuff not sure if
it's like that in all videos but that's
really good and uh just just just to
tell you
um uh go back to the older videos
uh yeah you know you're not gonna
tell you what we'll make a commitment to
being clean if
for whenever we cover your videos we're
more we're cleaner than we once were
that fart i smelled in the in the dub
was about as edgy as we'll get for you
i promise thank you for being you man
thank you george you rock
say hi to your wife for me and not in a
dirty way if you were another youtuber
oh man would i be making so many jokes
about going after your wife but not
today and he will
i'm clean your wife and i are completely
mutual i don't even know what she looks
like or her name
dude no jokes here that's heckin a lucky
woman and you say good to her george
yeah you stay g-o-o-d g-o-m
films and you know whenever people don't
remember my name
they always think it's george for some
reason because i just see the g
and i get a couple e's some of the
letters it's
uh what's it called uh a malga
are an anagram anagram yeah yeah gregory
and george
[Music]
see you guys subscribe to geoff
[Music]